voici Tom villa mon CDD
am
comment ça va mon tome ça va je suis
désolé Thierry ça va tout va bien super
tout va bien bon c'est la fin du warm up
comme à chaque fin de warm up depuis la
semaine dernière
Thierry petit débrief des tweets de la
semaine dernière n'hésitez pas à
commenter l'émission en direct
#slt on les lira la semaine prochaine la
semaine dernière vous avez confié
Thierry ne jamais porter de slip et on a
reçu ce petit tweet qui nous dit
Ardisson sans slip rue qui est sans
chaussettes j'ai du mal à comprendre le
concept
c'est très simple c'est une émission où
les invités doivent être très bien voilà
non ça lui était rien c'est comme au
McDo c'est venez comme vous aide voilà
ces femmes pouvaient retirer votre
chemise Miki votre manteau et Henri non
il y a des gamins qui regardent
non d'ailleurs j'ai repéré aussi ce
tweet d'Hugo qui nous dit dans Salut les
Terriens les applaudissements sont
forcés
mais non c'est pas vrai Thierry les gens
pensent que voilà tout ce qui se passe à
la télé c'est faux
alors que le public est parfaitement
libre de faire ce qu'il veut voilà
et puis pour terminer la semaine
dernière vous avez fait un débat sur le
thème de tweeter Thierry et d'ailleurs
vous n'avez pas de compte Twitter non
comme la remarqué cette internaute qui
s'appelle Tony qui a dit ça serait bien
de faire le premier tweet de tirer
Ardisson en direct comme le pape
exactement alors du coup je vous ai fait
un petit compte Thierry je crois que le
moment est venu c'est mon premier tweet
qu'est-ce que vous marquez Thierry parce
que moi
[Applaudissements]
bon n'hésitez pas à tout commenter
hashtags
très très beau plateau ce soir Thierry
Sophie davantrigano et un rappeur
habillé en fille on dirait un camouflocs
bonsoir j'adore Sophie alors Sophie je
rassure vous êtes ici en sécurité et
c'est pas parce qu'il y a Stéphane de
gros tu vas faire des jeux de mots sur
autre nom de famille voilà en plus votre
nom de famille ne vous va pas du tout
n'est pas du tout d'avant au même titre
que Catherine Deneuve n'est pas du tout
bref
Sophie Davant vous présenter c'est au
programme tous les matins sur France 2
et bientôt vous aurez votre nouvelle
émission tous les samedis à 17h45 bravo
France 2 en plus de lui avoir pété ses
nuits vous allez lui [__] tous ces
week-ends
[Applaudissements]
le prochain invité c'est celui qui
connaît le plus intimement Nicolas
Sarkozy tout juste après sa femme ce
n'est pas son proctologue c'est Henri
Guaino madame monsieur
Henri Guaino vous êtes député des
Yvelines anciens conseiller spécial du
président Sarkozy en fait pour faire
simple c'est vous qui lui écriviez c'est
discours ça doit être marrant d'être la
plume des puissants moi j'écris les
tweets de Thierry Ardisson voilà vous
avez écrit le discours de Dakar bon
après c'est pas la même chose que la
différence c'est quand tu écris une
connerie nous il y a trois connards qui
nous insulte alors que lui il a un
continent au cul donc ça c'est quand
même en tout cas heureusement vous avez
pas été la plume de Coluche pour sa
présidentielle sinon vous auriez pas
fini au même endroit ça c'est alors
Henri vous vous étiez candidat à la
première républicaine il faut d'avoir eu
l'île le nombre de parrainages mais vous
allez en parler je suis pause vous
partez à la présidentielle tout seul et
je trouve ça très courageux ou
inconscient mais ça c'est non mais ça se
présenter la présidentielle alors qu'on
a pas réussi à choper les parrainages de
son propre parti c'est comme
être foulée au bal du lycée et tenter
d'y aller tout seul à deux heures du
matin en se disant on sait jamais s'ils
sont bourrés ça peut passer
bon Miki Blanco
hello les Terriens
Sophie davantage
quand elle fait des selfies on s'en fout
Stéphane de Groodt very God acteur
voilà d'ailleurs il peut jouer une
chanson française si vous voulez do you
know la digue du cul
non non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous êtes un rappeur vous êtes noir et
gay alors heureusement que vous étiez
pas musulman sinon vous aviez tous les
critères pour être le pire ennemi de
Donald Trump
non plus d'être noir et gay vous êtes
juifs et c'est sûr que si vous aviez été
blonde il y a trois blagues sur 4 qui le
faisaient Paris du tout c'est quand même
bon Miki Blanco j'avoue que noir gay et
juif c'est pas évident
si Sophie Davant par exemple vous
faisiez encore toute une histoire vous
auriez fait une spéciale d'une semaine
sur nous ça c'est Stéphane de gros
Stéphane grosse rentrée théâtrale et la
sortie du best-of de de vos chroniques
en livre du coup j'ai essayé très très
modestement de faire votre portrait à la
manière de vous tout simplement Stéphane
de Groodt de Lascaux ou
plutôt et sans Mickey de Bruxelles en
Belgique où vous êtes né sans parler de
votre appendice de trèfle ou de cœur
comme l'homme que vous êtes etc etc
début de carrière en marche avant par
les circuits auto en manuel mais sans
valse et ce qui vend les sapins
contrairement à Ayton qui Sénat la fin
de sa vie en finissant lui dans la
barrière et non dans Alain Barrière
sinon il aurait eu ma vie
Monte-Carlo bien entendu mais il court
dehors c'est pas pour ça qu'il veut de
la Suze Uka et Monza à ta mère avant que
ça soit la cata Luna mais cette vie ne
vous plaît pas et pourtant cette vie
c'est pas mal vous vous aimiez les
caméras comme Dany Boon qui aime une
caméra mais ce sont les les jeux de mots
motus qui vous attire sans tirer la
boule noire car noir c'est noir il n'y a
plus d'espoir belle Hélène souvent
comparé à Raymond au Devos Raymond nous
vivons lui n'est plus là et vous avez
dorénavant installé votre propre style
Loving You c'est dans le supplément qui
disait la vérité et qui était gratuit
pour une fois qu'on vous a connu bien
que habillé aux côtés de Maïtena biraba
qui rira le dernier
ouais Stéphane pour votre pièce où il
est préférable de payer en carte bleue
car comme dit l'adage on ne rend pas la
monnaie de la pièce vous jouez tout ce
que vous voulez au théâtre Edward 7 et
sans voir Suzette on en perd la tête
comme disait Louis XVI car il faudrait
être patient dans la salle d'attente car
Bernard murale entrée heureusement il
est co-écrites par Matthieu Delaporte et
qui est sorti de ses gonds on fera au
cas par cas dit-il de toute façon la
paire il y en a pas deux ça c'est bien
c'est un très bon
Stéphane de route vous êtes au côté de
Bérénice B jjo une pièce où on en prend
plein les yeux comme dirait Clara
Morgane quoi depuis normal d'être ébloui
car un gros bijou dans un bel écrin ça
brille merci Stéphane
on va pas faire les bonnes habitudes on
va passer maintenant ok Thierry Ardisson
n'a pas voulu vous poser
Henri Guaino Henri vous avez déclaré je
suis sûr que Nicolas Sarkozy est honnête
vous pouvez le redire sans rire
perdu alors Nikki Blanco Miki vous êtes
un rappeur et vous êtes un gros militant
des droits des des gays aux États-Unis
ça veut dire que vous quand vous
rappelez vous niquez ma mère et mon père
en même temps
et pour terminer Sophie d'avant vous
dites que c'est après avoir accompagné
un ami voir son chirurgien esthétique
que vous êtes laissé tenter par une
intervention votre ami c'était Igor
Grichka
bon salut mon petit
de ne rien rater de Inna larditude
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu